-As the trial of his ex-campaign
chairman gets under way
and his former lawyer
turns on him,
President Trump
is getting even more desperate
for the adoration of his crowds.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can tell the walls
are closing in on Trump
because he keeps reacting
to the Russia investigation
in increasingly desperate ways.
He's gone all the way
from insisting
he had nothing to do with Russia
to saying there was no collusion
to claiming that
even if there was collusion,
it's not a crime,
to demanding that
the investigation be shut down.
He's like a murder suspect
who says,
"I didn't kill anyone,
and besides,
it was self-defense."
[ Laughter ]
And yet the occasional
Republican efforts
to hold Trump accountable have
not inspired much confidence.
For example, you might know
this famous Internet meme,
known as the "This is fine" dog.
It's been around for years.
Well, yesterday,
during a hearing
on Russian
election interference,
Republican Senator Richard Burr
seemed to have
learned about that meme
for the very first time.
-Some feel that we,
as society,
are sitting in a burning room,
calmly drinking a cup of coffee,
telling ourselves,
"This is fine."
That's not fine.
-Oh, my God.
There is nothing worse
than an old Senator entering
a meme into the public record.
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. Chairman, I would like
to yield the balance of my time
to our first witness,
Salt Bae.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, the President's
trying to shut down
an investigation
into his campaign
for colluding
with a foreign adversary,
and that's your response?
Let me put it to you this way --
some feel
that the Republican Party
is like a frog sipping tea,
saying,
"The President is a criminal,
but that's none of my business."
[ Laughter ]
And despite --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Despite Trump's insistence
that collusion is not a crime,
conspiracy to commit fraud
or violate election laws
very much are crimes.
And many former prosecutors,
even cautious ones,
are beginning to argue that
there's already enough evidence
in the public record
to prove those crimes.
-Are you seeing enough pieces
come to light
in just what is public facing
in this investigation
that you believe there
will be enough to charge someone
with a conspiracy to coordinate
or receive assistance
from a hostile foreign power?
-Yes, I am.
There are bits and pieces
in the public record
that suggest
that it wasn't just Russians.
So there's
some unanswered questions,
but I think
the pieces are there.
-Of course they're there.
The guy publicly asked Russia
to hack his opponent,
his son
took a meeting with them,
and his closest aides
all look like gangsters
from a Tex Avery cartoon.
[ Laughter ]
Which is why Trump is getting
increasingly hysterical
in his calls to end
the investigation
before its findings
become public.
Yesterday, he tweeted his
Attorney General Jeff Sessions
"should stop this rigged
witch hunt right now."
And his lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
challenged
Special Counsel Robert Mueller
to come forward
with everything he knows.
-We believe
that the investigation
should be brought to a close.
We think
they're at the end of it.
They should render their report,
put up -- I mean, I guess,
if we were playing poker --
we're not -- put up or shut up.
-It is very lucky you're
not playing poker, Rudy,
because Robert Mueller
has resting poker face.
[ Laughter ]
And you have the face of someone
who has just
been stuck with a hot poker.
[ Laughter ]
Giuliani then complained
that his team has had to respond
to several accusations,
including accusations leveled
by Trump's former lawyer and
personal fixer Michael Cohen,
who said last week
that Trump knew in advance
about that infamous 2016 meeting
at Trump Tower
with Russian officials.
-We have every reason to believe
they don't have anything,
the President
didn't do anything wrong,
they don't have any evidence
he did anything wrong.
They have lots of stuff
that goes up this alley
and that alley.
Last week, we were chasing
all these things about Cohen.
-Yeah, they have lots of stuff.
It's called evidence.
[ Laughter ]
If your boat has one leak,
maybe you hit a rock.
If it has 100 leaks,
maybe you have a [bleep] boat.
[ Laughter ]
Now, if Trump was directing
his Attorney General,
who is supposed to be
recused from the investigation,
to shut down the investigation,
that seems like a pretty obvious
case of obstruction of justice,
which is why Giuliani tried
to insist it wasn't an order,
it was just an opinion.
-No, it isn't.
It isn't at all.
It's what it is, as we said
immediately, it's an opinion.
And he used his --
He used a medium that he uses
for opinions -- Twitter.
And one of the good things
about using that is,
he's established a clear
sort of practice now
that he expresses
his opinions on Twitter.
He used the word "should."
He didn't use the word "must."
-I'm sorry.
Do you really think Donald Trump
is gonna agonize
over the difference
between "should" and "must"?
A couple weeks ago,
he called his wife Melanie.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday, he misspelled
the word "smoking."
[ Laughter ]
He's not sitting over parchment,
dipping a quill into an inkwell,
debating which word to use.
"Thou art -- no!
Thou shalt."
[ Laughter ]
Trump just dumps
the ink on the paper
and then smears it around
with his finger.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Giuliani...
[ Applause continues ]
Giuliani also insisted
that Trump can't be guilty
of obstruction of justice
because he has the power
to shut down the investigation
if he wants to.
So where does Giuliani
get that idea?
He was asked that question
yesterday.
And if I were his client,
his answer would not inspire
much confidence.
-Of course it's a crime.
No, under Article II
of the Constitution,
I'm not gonna tell you
my opinion on it
because I haven't really
gotten to the conclusion
of researching it.
-You haven't gotten to it?
It's Article II.
[ Laughter ]
Did you read Article I
and then just take a nap?
[ Laughter ]
It says a lot about your case
when this is the best lawyer
you can get to represent you.
You want a guy
who sounds like Atticus Finch.
Rudy sounds like he just
wandered out of Central Park
wearing an open hospital gown.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at him --
he's literally
wiping sweat from his brow.
Could you imagine
this guy in court?
"The defense may now call
its first witness."
"We're supposed
to have witnesses?
Oh, boy!
Oh, Rudy!
Oh, you done it again, Rudy.
You done it again!"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"Mr. Giuliani, are you ready
for a press conference?"
"Yeah, just bring me
my sweat rag!
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, all of this
has taken an emotional toll
on Trump.
CNN reports that
people inside the White House
say he's been in a dark place.
So, welcome aboard.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I mean...
In response,
he's been seeking solace
and emotional support
from his crowds,
which is why he held another one
of his public therapist sessions
on Tuesday in Florida,
where he once again
relived the glory days
of his campaign.
-They said it couldn't be done.
It was actually done
quite easily.
We won quite handily.
We were never off center stage.
You know what that means, right?
The debates.
We never left center stage.
We won every farm state.
You got to see
that middle of that --
Wasn't even the middle.
It was about everything but
the little corners of each side.
But you have to see,
that is all red.
Republican red.
Beautiful Republican red.
And you know what they were
asking on election day?
"Where did all these people
come from?"
You know where they came from?
They came from the heart.
They came from people that
were never happy with anybody
until we came along.
-"They were never happy with
anybody until we came along."
Trump talks about himself
the way a romance novel
talks about
the sexy pirate character.
[ Laughter ]
"She was never happy
with anybody...
until he came along.
He made her so lustful,
she had to wipe the sweat
from her brow."
[ Laughter ]
This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]